did you ever have a a friend who just
disappeared one day there were many guys
that I knew one day were gone the next
big Tony his name was real tough guy
standup Soldier guy and he said to me
I'm in a lot of trouble I said what
happened he says I got involved in a
little drug deal and the boss's son was
with me we sold to an undercover agent
and I said all right don't worry about
it I'll straighten it out you've been a
guy for a long time you're very well
respected I get on a plane I had a plane
at that time and I head down to Florida
and I get a call from another one of my
guys she says and I got to believe this
I said why he said Tony went into a
phone booth and blew his brains out
you're told straight out you know your
best friend is going to walk you into
that room so even though I was trying to
assure him he said Mike I know the life
too well and he had said I'm not going
to let that happen to me went into a
phone booth cuz I knew his wife and and
he he called her up and he said I love
you I love the kids and she didn't
understand what he was doing and
[Music]
boom